but your Fred doesn't have a will no oh
yeah so you got a will watch this Prell
event think about prevail you have a
will oh my god it's being selfish I'm
not being selfish it just haven't gone I
went up to it
does Richard have a will ask I went over
to mount pilot guess what now I have a
baby but I don't have a will there's
nothing left for your bubby buddy I'm
sorry I died now you don't have 50 bucks
and a pound guys do you have a 401k
you mean child didn't have a 401k no
bitching Ronnie doesn't have a will no
get out of here he's like [ __ ] 70
years old on that she doesn't have a
where's Ronnie coming in Ronnie answer
the question yes or no no no why you
don't have a will no are you out of your
[ __ ] mind
what are you doing you really will leave
a mess behind why am i dying nobody said
you were done by car you're gonna die
yeah I know 70 years old care of it
don't worry one of these days oh my god
of course he does but Stephanie and you
are not married right right so something
happened to you today she's entitled to
zero yeah that's right I haven't worked
out no you don't yeah I do how you got
it worked
are you about it I got it worked out
Ronnie doesn't realize he's in the
homestretch you're not a young man he's
on the back nine you understand what I'm
saying
it's not even 9:00 left this is the
eighth-inning
I'm on the back tree Stephanie gets the
dildo by the way still dough in the lube
you got to get on that today Ron and
really he's got it all worked out huh
he's got nothing worked out they do what
how do you have a worked out
how I do how do you have them worked out
if you don't have a will if it's in the
name why would their name now yeah
Stephanie I'm hiding my money in my
[ __ ] entire fortune is all my entire
fortune sold out to different people yes
already
yes Fred Trump yeah I'm Fred Trump yeah
my stocks and bonds are in by Derby hat
do what you want man that's gonna be
love gone down you have this beautiful
young fiance dude what are you gonna
leave her my skull shirts
gougers yes culture JD gets my [ __ ] sink
they sink you used to watch today did I
take my shits in and wash my hair you're
gonna leave that to JD hey JD
buddy I'm getting buried with the dragon
though the Christmas should you put